How do we raise self-reliantkids
who have initiative,
are resilient,
and can be problem solvers?
I believe we do that by
raising kids who can think
and act entrepreneurially.
Whether a childchooses to build a company
or become an employee,
it doesn't matter because
every kid needsto learn
how to think like an entrepreneur.
And the sooner we do this as parents,
createan environment at home
where they have the opportunity
and multiple occasions to challengetheir
beliefs about what's possible within them,
to step outside of their comfortzone,
to take risks, to learn from failure,
to bounce back from rejection.
Then the sooner will put them on
the path of living out their potential
to leadvery fulfilling and successful lives.